Anopheles mosquitoes are up to ten
millimeters long they insert their
proboscis into the skin of humans and
other animals to extract blood in the
process infecting the host with an often
deadly disease malaria claims the lives
of around half a million people a year
primarily in Africa and Southeast Asia
the risk of fatal complications is
especially high among children
there have been continuous efforts to
develop a vaccine to get the disease
under control but to date only with
moderate success developing a vaccine
against malaria is difficult for us it
see a malaria parasite is very complex
with a large genome is a big organism
and one with a high mutation capability
by just a few months ago it was revealed
that a malaria vaccine would soon be
approved for use however the drug was
found to be ineffective with many of the
test subjects unhappy with the results
the researchers here at Tubingen
University have been looking for a new
and hopefully more effective solution
for Forrester's what makes this new
process special is that we are going
back to the origins of vaccination we
take the living parasite and inject a
medicinal style highly purified sample
into a human but together with an
anti-malaria drug the Dunham anti
malaria Mickey in other words the
individual is injected with malaria but
at the same time is given an agent that
kills off the pathogen the malaria
parasite enters the liver where can be
detected by the body's immune system as
it leaves the liver and enters the
bloodstream the malaria drug moves in
and kills the parasite the parasite
triggers an immune response in the liver
with white blood cells or leukocytes
destroying the liver cells infected
at the same time antibodies are formed
in the blood to counter the parasite the
process helps the body to build up a
defense or immunity to any future attack
from malaria pathogens once patients
have been injected with another dose of
malaria they are protected we saw a high
level of protection in the first
experiment 100% although our test group
was small a major advantage of the
vaccine is that the pathogens cannot
become resistant to it the team in
Tubingen have now begun clinical tests
the final stage before government
approval is the next step is having to
monitor tolerance in large groups and
then its effectiveness in those areas
where malaria is prevalent especially in
Africa Asia and the Americas until that
vaccine is available people will have to
resort to conventional measures such as
insecticides and repellents or protect
themselves with mosquito nets